what is food
food is any nutritious substance that
people or animals eat or drink or that
plants absorb in order to maintain life
and growth
my name is ben brown and i'm a filmmaker
working with great big story
i've always taken an interest in
nutrition but over the last few years
i've been asking myself
what does food really mean to me
every day we are confronted with endless
conflicting information about what we
should and should not be eating
sugar-free low-fat gmo msg naturally
added flavors as convenience and price
take priority over quality and health we
find ourselves becoming disconnected
from the food that sustains us
in search of some simple answers i
traveled to costa rica to meet a farmer
who abandoned the fast-paced city life
to reconnect with food by growing it
himself i'm henry henry karczynski i'm
manager of villa vanilla
a organic biodynamic spice farm i grow
spices here in the central pacific of
costa rica i started in chicago i grew
up in chicago i had a couple jobs i
remember getting in my car you know i
had
visit clients on the north side of
chicago i would like go right to the
drive-in
get my big mac and french fries and a
soft drink and then head out on the road
to my next contact i mean i would do
that
when i was 24 it's a rat race and
everybody's trying to struggle to get up
the ladder and then when they get to the
top they go what did i do with my life
you know it's already too late
and i had a sort of restart look at what
am i going to do and
a little seed started growing in me to
actually do my own thing i just had
something growing in me
to grow to grow plants to grow food
to do a farm and i was introduced to
biodynamics from the book the secrets of
the soil
i think the most impact that had was
that it removed those blindfolds and i
was able to see the
big picture
you know in a way a mission i have is to
use the farm as a
sort of a message for people to look at
at food
we are living on this planet and
we're also here to enjoy the pleasures
the food
the sensuality of living on this planet
food is a flavor it's an aroma it's uh
it's something to enjoy
so what i would actually recommend to
people that are starting that first
journey is start a garden grow your
tomatoes grow your lettuce you know make
that first step uh you'll be blown away
on how much
that how good that food tastes and uh
and you can be starting connecting with
mother earth
the most important thing is to get that
take that first step as i said at one
time i was a little bit
discouraged because of the environments
but recently there's optimism
there's lights
at that end of that tunnel
i share henry's optimism for change we
already know about the endless health
benefits of eating natural organic
produce
but i also believe that by improving our
relationship with food we can reconnect
with this beautiful planet
to consume consciously is to take action
against the destructive objectives of
large-scale food production
mother earth is a beautiful biological
system
so we must keep it simple
take responsibility
and work to protect the only home we
have
you